getting a job in Tech has always been
hard but wow 2023 has been a whole new
challenge with so much competition and
limited job openings you might be left
wondering is it even possible to land a
tech job this year if you're feeling
this way you're definitely not alone
according to layoff star FYI over 150
000 Tech employees have lost their jobs
in just the first three months of 2023.
that's nearly the size of Google's
entire Workforce and not to mention
artificial intelligence has started to
completely disrupt the tech industry
with predictions that it would replace
more than 85 million jobs by 2025. I
landed my first six-figure tech job at
AWS around two and a half years ago but
back then the tech industry was booming
and tech companies were hiring rapidly
to keep up with the growth unfortunately
things didn't stay that way for long and
the economy took a downturn but on the
bright side there are now tools like
chai GPT that can make your job search
process a lot easier in today's video I
want to provide you with the exact steps
I would follow to land a high-paying
Tech job and more specifically how you
can use apt as a powerful tool to help
you get there so whether you're someone
just starting out or you're looking to
make a career change make sure you watch
it till the end of this video because
I'll be sharing with you the exact
prompts you can copy and paste directly
into chat GPT to get hired in 2023.
before we get started make sure you give
this video a like And subscribe to the
channel because I make videos like this
every single week okay so here's the
exact roadmap I would follow if I have
to start over first I'd research and
identify the companies I'm interested in
this could be done through online job
boards company websites or even LinkedIn
next I'd work on optimizing my resume to
make sure it stands out to potential
employers I would highlight any relevant
skills and experience and tailor my
application to the specific company once
I have my resume ready I will then start
applying to open jobs it's important at
this stage to not just rely on online
applications but also network with
others in the industry so while I wait
to hear back I'd also focus on improving
my skills and knowledge this can be done
through online courses certifications
and personal projects and then once I
start getting interviews I will prepare
for them by practicing interview
questions now the good news is tragedy
PT can actually assist you with each
step of the process hoping you save up
to 80 of the time you'll normally spend
perfecting your resume preparing for
interviews and so on let me show you how
as I've mentioned earlier the first step
is to come up with a list of companies
you're interested in so open up chatgpt
and type in ask me five questions to
understand my career situation once I
answer the questions in the next message
provide me with a list of jobs and
companies you would recommend so chai
GPT is going to ask you five questions
to understand your current job and you
know your educational background and
then what are some of your goals so just
go ahead and provide charge EBT with all
those responses but I'm just going to
type in I'm someone looking to learn and
a job in the cloud with not much
experience and then based on my response
you can see that they recommended five
rules for me across five different
companies so I think this can provide a
really good starting point if you have
no idea what you want to get into and
you want chai Chi BT to suggest some
companies and roles for you let's say
I'm interested in the first row which is
the cloud support associate role at AWS
I could type in what are the skills
required to become the first role and
then it says to become a cloud support
associate at AWS you may need technical
knowledge troubleshooting skills
communication skills and so on you can
even go a step further and ask about the
salary so what is the average salary of
this role in the United States and then
it says that according to Glassdoor
average salary in the US is 73k per year
however one limitation of charge GPT is
that it's not able to browse the
internet for the latest information this
means that it won't be able to help you
find the current job openings in your
area so my recommendation would be to
use a job search website like indeed
alongside chat GPT for example let's say
I do a search on indeed and find this
associate Cloud engineer role what I can
do is copy this entire job description
and then paste it into chachibi team and
then at the bottom I can write provide
me a DOT Point summary of this job
description and you can see that
charging PT pretty much summarizes the
entire job description based on the job
title job type even goes through the
duties as well as the required skills
you could also ask what are the key
skills I need to include on my resume
for this role and then it says based on
the job description here are a list of
the roles to include on your resume you
can see Cloud certifications hands-on
experience with aw us and a bunch of
other skills this will not only help you
save time in reading the entire job
description but also helps you figure
out what skills you will need on your
resume speaking of resumes I found out
that Chad GPT could actually tailor your
resume in less than 30 seconds all you
have to do is type in act as a
professional resume writer and tailor my
resume based on the job description and
then type in here is my resume and what
we're going to do is provide charge gbt
with a copy of my resume this is just a
sample resume and I can provide a copy
of this resume in the video description
I'll copy and paste this into chargpt
and then I'll also copy and paste the
job description so I'll be like here is
the job description copy that job
description that we had from the job
posting and then here's the updated
resume that chai GPT is suggesting and
almost instantly Chachi PT provides a
resume tailored to the specific job
description I can't really tell what
changes they made here which is maybe a
good thing because the resume might have
been already quite tailored to it but
let me just ask what changes did you
make and then try GPT provides a list of
the changes so they've updated my career
summary to highlight the certification
and the focus on these skills hmm okay
this is interesting they added a
certification that I didn't originally
have on my resume so just make sure you
don't fully rely on charge BT to create
your resume always double check to see
if there were any changes that were
incorrect let me just let charging
Beauty know that I don't have that
certification previously on the resume
so second point is not correct the
resume
doesn't have that certification so
tragic PT is apologizing now and I'll
just say rewrite my resume to correct
the error okay and then it provides me
with an updated resume without that
additional certification now that you
have your resume ready The Next Step
will be to start applying to jobs
however instead of just filling in
online applications make sure you also
reach out to others for help you can
start by identifying people in your
network who might be able to give you
advice or referrals this could be from
colleagues mentors or even people you
went to school with but then comes the
question what type of messages should
you send to reach out to people let's
say you stumble across the post on
LinkedIn about a job opening for a cloud
engineer role at Amazon you can ask
charging PT to craft a LinkedIn Outreach
message to connect with a hiring manager
at Amazon for a cloud engineer role wow
okay this message is is pretty good but
I think it's getting a bit too long so
just ask Chachi PT make this message
more concise and I think also ask it to
have a stronger call to action okay so
this is much shorter and you can see
that there's more of a direct call to
action aside from writing LinkedIn
messages charging PT can also help you
come up with cover letters but instead
of just asking Chad gbt can you write me
a cover letter for this role I'd
recommend asking chai GPT to guide you
along the process and gather more detail
about the role and Company you're
applying for for instance you can type
in act as a professional cover letter
writer and ask me questions to guide me
through creating my cover letter okay so
Chachi BT is asking you a set of
questions to get more of an idea of what
cover letter you need you can just go
ahead and answer these questions and
Chad gbt will be able to help you write
a cover letter okay so as you're
building your res resume and networking
with others another important part of
this process is continuously building
your technical skills let me introduce
you to yellowtail Tech an organization
dedicated to helping people with no I.T
background land their very first
high-paying Tech job they have just
released an AWS technical Essentials
course offering live online classes to
help you learn AWS I started my career
at AWS so I'm a bit biased but honestly
I believe that learning cloud is one of
the best ways to land a job in I.T
yellowtail tax course covers the core
AWS services and common Solutions it
also provides you with hands-on
experience and knowledge as you can see
here the course starts off with a basic
introduction into AWS and then
progresses into topics like compute
networking and so on so if you're
someone looking to get your foot in the
tech industry through cloud computing
I'll leave a link in the description
below to their online classes a big
thank you to yellowtail tech for
partnering with me on this video okay
here comes the fun part or should I say
the part I find the most terrifying
whenever I applied for jobs the part I
dreaded the most was the interview stage
but when I look back the main reason for
this was a fear of uncertainty it was a
fear of not knowing what type of
questions my interviewer might ask or
whether my answers were strong enough
now Chachi BT can actually help you with
both of those concerns you can use it to
prepare for Technical and non-technical
interview questions but ask it to
provide you with questions as well as
feedback on how to improve your answers
let's go back to using the example of a
cloud engineer role at AWS imagine
you've reached the interview stage and
you need some help with preparing for
the interview you can type in from now
on you are my interviewer for a cloud
engineer role at AWS ask me my first
interview question okay first question
is tell me about your experience with
cloud computing and how it relates to
your work as a cloud engineer this is
quite a typical first question employers
usually want to hear about your
experience with the cloud so for example
I'll type in hi I'm Lucy I worked in
tech support for two years nice okay you
can see that it's quite conversational
almost like a real interviewer so what
you can do is you can either continue on
this interview and chai GPT will keep
asking you questions as if they're your
interviewer or you can ask Chad GPT for
feedback so how can I improve my
previous response because you know my
answer was quite short and I want to see
what advice charger BT has for me to
improve my interview answer and now
Chachi PT provides me with a much more
detailed response for That interview
question if you just want a whole list
of questions that you can prepare in
your own time just ask something like
provide me with a list of Technical and
non-technical questions for the cloud
engineer role at AWS and you can pretty
much just copy and paste all these
questions and prepare for them in your
own time okay so in summary Chachi PT
can help you through the entire job
search process from the initial research
all the way to the actual interview I've
collated a list of all the prompts I've
mentioned in the video into a Google doc
with bonus ones that I didn't have time
to cover in the video if you've watched
this video all the way through comment
below with your favorite way to use chai
gbt and I'll see you soon bye for now